you
every Tuesday our ion money series looks
at financial issues Americans face this
morning we're focusing on a fast-growing
trend saving aggressively to retire
early the movement is called fire and it
stands for financial independence retire
early the idea is to live a frugal life
now so you can take control of your
financial future 34 year old Kirsten
Saunders and her husband Julian embraced
the movement they say fire is helping
them achieve financial independence we
are on target to hit our financial
independence number our fire number and
2021 our number is 1.3 million the
intuition behind it is fairly simple
it's save your money so that you don't
have to work forever for me the the step
for fired was to eliminate the debt I
was a huge spender and I was just
spending way more than I earned housing
transportation and food for most people
are the largest expenses that you have
and so if you can do whatever it takes
to keep that cost low or eliminate it
altogether that's going to be a huge way
to boost your savings over time we
obviously invest in index funds and in
the market but we have two rental homes
that are income generating investments
and then we continue to invest in
vehicles like 401ks IRAs HSAs
I think the biggest misconception of the
fire movement would be how extreme it is
we have the average or national savings
rate is incredibly low and so we look at
that and say that that's actually pretty
extreme that people aren't preparing for
their futures the retirement for us is
meaningful work CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
what financial strategies we can learn
from this movement Jill good morning
good morning what how did this get
started you know it was really a
reaction against the Great Recession a
lot of the older Millennials had
suffered so much and they saw what
happened to their parents they said oh
we got to get going and so the
philosophy is really interesting as we
saw in that piece it's let me live
frugally today let me save as much as I
possibly can and then I may be able to
retire early but I think really what
they're talking about is have control be
able to have maybe a second career that
is meaningful a lot of the founders of
movement really talked about this is
around happiness and you don't find
happiness by buying a lot of stuff it
seems impressive to me what they're
doing what's the downside why is her
number when I'd never heard of the fire
movement neither did you don't I send
what I get but they seem to be doing it
right what's the downside where there
have been some financial journalists and
some people in the business who say oh
they're giving false hope to many
Americans in other words you're really
not going to be able to retire early
because you've got such a long life
ahead of you listen these kids are
probably gonna live til they're 90 95
even a hundred but I would say this
anything that gets us in the habit of
saving and questioning why we are
spending the way we are spending a lot
of these folks who wrote adhere to this
movement they've got a side hustle a
little part-time job not because they
want to be great entrepreneurs they want
to find a way to get a little bit more
money in the door so they can hit these
goals I think this is laudable it is
laudable but I know two-thirds of young
people Millennials who are employed
don't have any savings at all a lot of
people don't have enough savings so is
this really only something for people
who are taking in huge paychecks
I think another criticism has been that
this started with a lot of the younger
folks who had high tech jobs so they had
ample pay so they could choose to do
this but I interviewed a bunch of the
fire adherance for my podcast and what
they said to me is that's actually not
the case that every single person makes
choices every week about how they spend
money so imagine if you could find 10 15
20 dollars but maybe you're just
throwing away and capture that money put
your savings on autopilot put a game
plan together I mean part of this
movement is we are asking people to say
what do you want your life to look like
how much do you spend today are you
tracking your expenses all of these are
fantastic habits to form so I am very
much a cheerleader for them so so Joe
where do you look to start to cut to
save money
I think the first piece is you've got to
track your expenses I think most of us
have this mindless spending habit and no
matter how much you make you know what
I'm talking about
there's 10 percent of the money that
comes in the door and you say I don't
where that went so tracking your money
becomes imperative then once you guys
also very scary you know funny you
should say I I liken it to diet and
exercise it's scary to step on the scale
if you need to lose weight it's scary to
go to the gym for the first time if you
haven't gotten a long time these are
steps in the process but only by doing
that tracking your money which is really
important can you identify some amount
of money to safe then you want to
automate that saving and maybe you want
to automate saving for retirement and
then you want to use the lowest cost
options available when you are investing
like index funds these are really good
practices even if you don't get to
retire when you're 40 or 50 what you do
gain is a sense of control and I think
that is imperative to make us feel much
better about how we handle our financial
I can honestly say I don't ever regret
saving money nobody does I don't know I
feel like spending why you got it the
past five minutes had no effect on every
day in your life I'm gonna die broke and
broken yeah that's a good philosophy
stuff we gotta go Joe thank you